We have a voicemail number two one nine two
David p.
It's been a while since we heard from Troy
York, but alas, here he is calling for my
deportation to a country I've never been to
as well as Sam Cedars and Kyle Kalinsky is
take a listen.
Kyle Klewicki should be deported to China.
Sam should be deported to Russia and David's
Hag.
We should be deported to the Dominican Republic.
The left as practicably hijacked the Democratic
Party and is totally gone insane.
Julio Castro once a Marshall Plan,
did he say Julio Castro?
Okay,
US spending money.
Julio, did you say?
No countries of the Banana Republic, the democratic
parties.
We totally Hersh, thanks mashed leaders arrested.
They're more of an anti-American party for
what runs this country.
Totally stupid for allowing this process to
root up within our grounding.
Again, Mr Pacman, you, you are part of the
problem.
You and the insane left progressive, you should
be deported to Dominican Republic.
Yeah.
So once again, this idea of deportation to
countries people have never been to is weird.
I mean I can't, I don't think Sam has been
to Russia, although maybe he has, I don't
know, Kyle's full travel background, but I
don't believe he's ever been to China.
I certainly have never been to the Dominican
Republic.
And this is just more of the same from Troy
York.
And I know that this is just a troll.
I understand that.
But there actually is this idea of um, framing
just basic socially democratic ideas from
the Democratic Party as an American in some
way.
And uh, what you have to understand is that
even some of the countries that are being
mentioned as places we should go to don't
have these policies.
I mean, does it, it's completely incoherent
and unfortunately in the anti intellectual
and pseudo intellectual era of Trump that
we are in, this is what passes as serious
analysis in some places.
I won't name the places on the Internet, the
enclaves.
I think many of you know what some of those
are.
That type of quote analysis from Troy York
actually counts as serious analysis in some
places and that's extraordinarily scary.
Make sure you are a member or a patron to
get instant access to the bonus show.
And I look forward to speaking the